هكذا تبدو محلات بيع الملابس النسويه في
العاصمه كابول وبقيه المدن الافغانيه
مجسمات عارضات ازياء اما مقطوعه الراس او
مغطاه بلاستيك او خرقه قماش قماشيا مع
قوانين طالبان صارمه
جميله لان المجسمات صنعت خصيصا لاستقطاب
الزبائن وهذا الامر اثر سلبا على عملنا
مسيح الله احد اصحاب محل بيع ملابس النساء
في كابول يقول انه خضع لاوامر طالبان
بتغطيه رؤوس مجسمات العارضات او قطعها وان
مسؤولي وزاره الامر بالمعروف والنهي عن
المنكر يراقبون السوق ويتفحصون هذه الدمى
بين الحين والاخر
على الرغم من اثاره السلبيه
وامام هذا التطور اللاسلكي لتعليمات
طالبان يشتكي اصحاب المتاجر الافغان من
تكبد خسائر ماليه كبيره
في مجسمات عارضات الازياء التي تكلف
الواحده منها بين 70 و80 دولارا في وقت
يشهد اقتصاد البلاد ركودا يضعه على وشك
الانهيار
تماثيل عرض الملابس تعتبرها طالبان اصناما
تعيد الناس لعصور ما قبل
الاسلام وينبغي حظرها امر يرفضه اصحاب
المتاجر وباعت الملابس الذين يخشون ان
يؤدي هذا الى غياب الزبائن وبالتالي
اختفاء ما تبقى من دخلهم عبد الله ناذر
العربيه كابول